NATO countries set a goal in 2014 to
spend at least 2% of their economies
gross domestic product on defense by
2024 we check defense spending numbers
from NATO and they show the United
States does contribute a larger share
than the other countries this year the
u.s. plans to spend three and a half
percent of GDP on defense more than all
of its partners most NATO countries are
increasing spending but only four others
are likely to hit that 2% guideline this
year 23 members will spend less than the
benchmark including Germany Ian Bremmer
is president of the Eurasia group and
senior global affairs contributor for
CBS News Ian's good morning president
Trump went after Germany for almost five
minutes a lot of sharp words are being
exchanged exchanged at this summit is
the NATO alliance in jeopardy well so
far what Trump has done is said if you
don't pay more I'm gonna make you really
uncomfortable and be really rude in
front of you okay I mean there's no or
else he hasn't said what he's going to
actually do if they continue to under
pay and the Germans are not going to
come close to the 2% commitment by 2024
they're good on all sorts of other
commitments of social spending for
example they're good on their climate
commitments but for some reason not on
defense
so the fact that Merkel and Trump really
can't stand each other and that this is
really the part of the transatlantic
relationship that is most rubbing
against each other was on obvious
display at the g7 it's on obvious
displays NATO opens but so far no direct
impact on NATO itself but those without
an understanding of history can you
explain why America shoulders most of
the burden well sure I mean the fact is
that the United States is the world's
largest you know sort of defense
expenditure in the world when the Soviet
Union collapsed you know the Europeans
no longer faced those direct threats the
Americans still had basis not just in
Europe but all over the world that it
was in our interest when Trump talks
about spending 3.5 percent of our GDP on
defense he's talking about our global
commitments he's also talking about the
fact that if you spend 20 years in the
military as enlisted man as my father
did you get a pension for life and as
the Germans have found out with the
Greeks it's really hard to rip those
pensions up I mean 10% of our spending
is on pensions for example so I mean
there are lots of reasons why our
defense spending is high Trump has
decided for his own reasons that he
wants to increase that defense spending
Germany has decided for their own
reasons they don't but I'll tell you
when he goes after German former
Chancellor Gerhard schröder on for
example selling them out on gas he has a
point
Schroder is an enormous embarrassment
for the German people
he has taken enormous personal financial
gain for baking the German government
more dependent the German people more
dependent on Russian energy it's kind of
like we you know we asked today about
Trump for the Clintons former Chancellor
schröder involved in that gas deal that
the president mentioned today family
meetings can be uncomfortable usually
you have the uncomfortable conversations
in these kind of diplomatic family
meetings behind closed doors not in
front of the cameras clearly the
president was teeing up this question of
gas with the cameras in front to sock
him in the nose why do you think he did
that um because he wants to make more
coal uncomfortable he was he doesn't
like any of these multilateral meetings
he feels like they are opportunities for
the Allies to gang up on the Americans
America's weaker he takes a Chinese
approach he wants a one-on-one meeting
where he's stronger and he wants to link
security to economics just like the
Chinese do like they'll give you money
if you play ball with them politically
in our security perspective it's the
same thing Trump is doing on the Chinese
he said you want to work with me on
North Korea I'll work with you on trade
South Korea you want me to defend you
you better give me what I want in a deal
Europeans you want me to complain or do
something right on NATO deal with trade
it's linkage and it's really not been
the American approach it's been the
Bayesian approach all right Ian Bremmer
thank you so much